feel like you're engaging with the
material like with the trolley problem
that was just tricky that's all why
don't you just tell me the right answer
well that's what's so great about the
trolley problem is that there is no
right answer
ah this is why everyone hates moral
philosophy professors come on your side
here dude but he is not wrong okay
Michael
trust me when it comes to human ethics
I just know more than you I've been
studying it my whole life it's just that
it's so theoretical you know I mean you
know maybe there's a more concrete
approach here let's try this
Oh God
Michael what did you do I made the
trolley problem real so we can see how
the ethics would actually play out there
five workers on this track and one over
there here are the levers to switch the
tracks then choice the biggies I mean
technically speaking it's tricky I mean
on the one hand of yours right or wrong
dude
okay so what do we learn Chiti talk it
out buddy
what do we think he thinks he just
killed a bunch of people with a trolley
it's just a simulation I would never
make you kill real people
oh well that's reassuring because some
of the parts of the fake people Michael
can we just go back to the classroom we
never left here I'll show you huh
look see buddy none of this was real
well they're fake people but their pain
is real does that make sense there have
to be stakes there's just another
thought experiment this is awful you
specifically asked me if there is a way
I could connect with the material or I'm
trying you guys sorry you're right I
want to help you understand this Thank
You Jenny so let's try again scenario
okay I can do this I am choosing to
switch tracks so that way I only kill
one person oh forgot to tell you this is
the scenario where you actually know one
of the people to friend Henry there oh
no it's Troy I can't change my boots are
stuck in the trash
again just a simulation and almost
impossibly lifelike simulation with
someone's foot really fly off their body
like that that was kind of cool
technically speaking
you